vous le connaissez comme président du
medef des yvelines bertrand de créer est
aussi directeur d'un supermarché à
fontenay le fleury son entreprise
bénéficie du crédit impôt pour la
compétitivité et l'emploi en 2016 il a
économisé environ 70000 euros
nous avons investi essentiellement sur
le service je l'avais cette bouche
boucherie peu fleuri forage coupe on a
fait les travaux cet été
embauche la salle en septembre le cic
eux c'est un put sur l'impôt sur les
sociétés à hauteur de 7 % des salaires
inférieurs à 2,5 fois le smic
dans les yvelines en 2014 près de 16000
employeurs ont bénéficié du dispositif
plus de 13000 en 2015 pour un montant
qui augmente de plus de 100 millions
d'euros en deux ans une mesure critiquée
par la cgt le cicr n'atteint pas les
objectifs que le gouvernement lui avait
fixés que ce soit en termes de création
d'emplois d'innovation
les deux candidats à l'élection
présidentielle souhaite transformer le
cic eux en allègements de charges pour
la candidate du front national la
priorité est donnée aux tpe pme sous
condition de maintien de l'emploi
emmanuel macron veut généraliser la
baisse des charges pour favoriser
l'embauché pour moi je ne sais pas
combien comment voilà aujourd'hui je ne
peux pas me prononcer est ce que ce sera
plus - que le cce
je sais pas nous on pense déjà que tous
les dispositifs qui baissent les
cotisations sociales des employeurs
c'est prouvé que c'est inefficace
concernant l'impôt sur les sociétés le
candidat en marche souhaite réduire le
taux de 33 3 % à 25 % à la fin de son
quinquennat
marine le pen propose un taux
intermédiaire à 24 % pour les pme